I obviously have been, you
know, I've, I've been very, uh,
didn't mention all trite
violence all that often,
but then you have to realize the alternate
is tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny. They're,
they're rare. They've admitted defeat.
You know, Richard Spencer said,
I think he said this at the
Antifa one or something.
No one showed up and he hit an
event in Florida. 11 people shut up.
I'm not worried about that guy.
I'm worried about these fringe
ideologies that are racist,
intolerant and violent. The slowly
seeping into our culture. Like
when you see politicians openly embrace
like race based government policy,
it's war. It really does
worry me. You know, my,
I think I have this perspective growing
up in a mixed race family where I've
been insulted by the left for being
white and I've been insulted by far right
racists for being, you know, a month.
And so I don't like either of it.
I really don't.
But the white supremacists types are
falling apart and they don't threaten me
anymore. They, they just don't.
But the left wing racism and,
and these ideas of racial equity and
determining what your worth based on the
color of your skin are becoming
more and more pervasive.
The lawsuit with Harvard that,
that Asians have a harder standard,
a tougher standard for getting in even
though agents or a smaller minority than
white people.
Why does that make sense?
Why should I have to approach
someone and justify my race to them?
That terrifies me. It really does. And
we, when we see Kirsten Gillibrand tweet,
the future is intersectional. We'll
intersectionality is that ideology of,
of race based policy. Okay.
Kazia Kurt has put forth, puts,
puts forth the green new deal
that says racial equity. I,
I prefer to judge someone on
the content of their character,
not the color of their skin.
While it's also,
that's the kind of talk that gets Trump
reelected. Oh God. And that's that one.
That's one of my biggest
pet peeves because you know,
I've talked about progressive tax.
I think we can do a lot for a public
option for expanding medicaid. Uh, the,
the idea of a green new deal at
its core to me is fascinating. Can,
can the government,
you know,
can we allocate tax money to invest
in new technologies, fusion, uh,
nuclear and reduce carbon
emissions and do great things?
Can we make high speed rails?
But then when you come out and say,
pay the unwilling and these other equity
things and intersectionality, I'm like,
that's, that's not, that's not what I'm
talking about. I can't support that.
The unwilling is the
most preposterous one.
The idea that someone's unwilling to
work and we need to provide them with a
living. That's insanity. I mean,
that's the ultimate progressive bend.
But in that's where it keeps going.
But where they're trying to out
progressive the next concept, but it,
but hold on in a socialist or
communist society stuff to work. Yeah.
I don't know what society exists where
you expect people to undertake the
greatest construction project
in the history of humanity.
A massive train network that
makes all planes obsolete,
but at the same time tell people they
don't have to work if they want money.
Well, this is what
we're saying. It's like,
as these ideologies get
more and more ridiculous,
they try to out progressive the next step.
Like it's a fundamental right
for you to earn a living. And,
and Pew Pew research recently put out
a poll last week, couple weeks ago,
Democrat, the Democratic Party, 54%
want more moderate policies. So I'm,
I fall in that bracket,
but still,
you still have about 43 or so that
want more left leaning policies. Oh,
that means the party split. And so
here, here's the problem. I see.
If you're going to put me up, if
you're gonna say, Tim, you got to vote.
You have to vote.
You have to make a choice.
You've got a moderate conservative who
believes things I really don't agree with,
but he doesn't want to give money to
people who don't work and he doesn't
believe in identitarian politics
and race equity or whatever.
And then you've got the Democrats
who are so far left to me,
I can't even see them anymore.
Who Do you think, you know, uh,
social liberals and liberals are gonna
vote for the closest person to them
politically will be a conservative. You
know, that's what scares me. You know,
we had this great future with a potential
for a public option for expanding
medicaid for, I mean, look, I, I really
do believe social programs are important.
We can do more.
I like a lot of what Bernie has to say.
I think we need to reform education,
but I think education could be expanded.
Again, I'm interested in, the idea
is I want to advocate for them,
but we need to figure out how to do it.
But my po, like where I fit politically,
I'm politically homeless. I don't agree
with someone judging me based on my race.
I've been through that.
Hell No. Never again.
People vandalizing my home because they
didn't like that at a brown mom and a
white dad,
I don't want to live in that world.
I don't want you to look me in the eyes
and say, I tell people, look at this way.
When it comes to Harvard,
I want you to look into the eyes of
that little Asian boy and say, honey,
you can't go to Harvard. You're Asian.
You look too much like those people.
How does that make sense?
Why is it that just because this
kid looks similar to this kid,
you're going to tell him he
has a harder standard for pat,
for the sats to get into the
school. I just, I, I refuse.